e aí
bom então pessoal eu sou médica formada
pela universidade federal de alagoas
estou me especializando em dermatologia
aqui em são paulo e atua na linha de
frente né do combate ao coronavírus aqui
no brasil mas apesar de tudo isso eu não
vim falar exatamente sobre isso na
verdade eu vim falar sobre histórias de
sucesso e como histórias de sucesso
podem ser limitantes e muitas vezes
adoecedor já parou para pensar nisso
quando me chamaram para palestrar aqui
né no sedex são paulo eu fiquei super
feliz muito honrada mas no início
imaginei que as pessoas iam esperar que
eu falasse sobre intermédica na poesia
sobre se tem uma mulher negra nesse
momento tão importante né de combate ao
racismo aqui no brasil e no mundo
eu vou falar um pouco da minha história
de menina do interior até mexe aqui na
capital são paulo para fazer a
dermatologia e todos os sistemas são
muito maravilhosas são muito importantes
na minha vida eu falo sobre isso
diariamente nas minhas redes sociais mas
gente essa não é a minha única história
e nem a mais importante e eu vou mostrar
para vocês porque mas antes eu quero
fazer um exercício com você tá eu quero
que vocês fecharem os olhos e se imagina
em uma fila de espera de hospital
imagine lá na recepção aí a
recepcionista chama vocês para ir para o
consultório médico você chega na porta
alí do consultório médico abre a porta e
o que você imagina encontrar lá qual o
seu imaginário desse médico
ah eu imagino que a maioria de vocês vai
esperar encontrar um homem branco de
meia-idade provavelmente né de roupa
social sério sisudo educado porém
gritante você imagina logo que ele deve
ser estudado arduamente que ele deve
estar muito e talvez ele não tenha tempo
para família com a vida é muito corrida
que ele ganha muito dinheiro que ele é
muito rico que ele está satisfeito com a
vida profissional dele afinal ele é
médico né você imagina também talvez que
ele não deva ter tatuagem porque deve
ter até proibido você tatuagem na
faculdade de medicina né imagina que ele
é uma pessoa bem-sucedida que ele tá
feliz e que agora missão da vida dele é
realmente só seguir o curso da medicina
esperar morrer em paz
eu já gerei talvez talvez sim exagerado
um pouco mais talvez não e agora
continuando nesse nosso exercício você
olha para mim
oi gente eu sou exatamente oposto desse
imaginário e desde o momento que eu
decidi fazer medicina que eu decidir ser
médica eu fico cobrada só o quadrado a
minha proxima de se imaginar e assim eu
fui cobrada não só para chegar lá né cê
médica de facto mas para provar o meu
sucesso profissional provar que eu sou
boa médica e essa gente é uma pressão
esmagadora e eu sei que muitos de vocês
não é cada um de nós tem esse imaginário
do sucesso que lhes é imposto mesmo que
você esteja dentro dos padrões sociais
mais convencionais eu sei que tem algo
aí que é o prestou na sua vida essa
prestam esmagadora então me diz
e qual o seu médico branco de meia-idade
qual é o imaginário do sucesso esperado
para você eu sei que você sabe essa
resposta que ela deve te assombrar
muitas vezes né no meu caso era esse
homem branco de meia-idade né esse
médico super-homem que me assombrava e
chegou uma época que eu fui tão cobrada
para ser semelhante a ele que eu estava
tão distante mas tão distante desse
imaginário que eu realmente achei que eu
tinha que mudar quem eu era para suprir
essas expectativas isso aconteceu logo
nos primeiros anos da faculdade de
medicina né eu era monalisa futura
médica centro estudiosos a dormia super
mal 45 horas de sono por dia tem um
grupo de fogo no final de semana só
pensava em estudar não tinha vida social
totalmente sedentária nele iniciava
minha autoestima totalmente sem vai
eu achava que não era algo importante
não tinha tempo para minha família eu
realmente me perdi desconectei de mim
mesma até que chegou um momento que não
aguentava mais que não dava mais para
ficar daquele jeito foi um momento que
eu percebi que eu não era só uma futura
médica uma estudante de medicina que eu
era muito mais do que aquilo eu comecei
a refletir que eu cresci sendo
estimulada né as e criativa a gostar de
arte de literatura gosta de música eu
era ness das medição all star wars então
essa hora senhor dos anéis eu tinha
muita curiosidade curiosidade de
descobrir o mundo curiosidade de
descobrir como funcionava o corpo humano
e eu acho que foi esta curiosidade essas
minhas características desse meu lado
mais criativo que me fez querer fazer
medicina então como é
é possível que eu precisava sufocar
todas essas mona lisas para ser uma só
para ser a monalisa médica não fazia
sentido para mim tá e eu realmente não
estava tarde seita e aí gente quando eu
descobri isso eu comecei o meu processo
de tirar as outras mona lisas do foram
de me conectar com a minha totalidade e
tudo começou a mudar tudo começou a
mudar e mudar para melhor isso se deu
exatamente no meio da faculdade de
medicina né e eu percebi que o primeiro
passo seria me reconectar com a mona
lisa preta e com a minha ancestralidade
e se eu te contar que aceitar o meu
cabelo natural me fez uma médica melhor
você vai me achar louca né mas foi
exatamente isso que aconteceu gente eu
entrei no processo de transição capilar
que é o processo de aceitar o seu cabelo
natural né eu alisar o meu cabelo desde
os 12 anos então foi um processo assim
de mudança completa à medida que o meu
cabelo crespo natural e a crescendo eu
ia crescendo com ele e a crescendo mais
forte mas empoderada mais conectada
comigo mesma e foi uma cascata assim de
coisas boas que foram acontecendo essa
tava tão feliz tão empolgada que eu
decidi criar um canal no youtube no meio
da da faculdade de medicina para falar
sobre cabelo sobre beleza sobre as
estima preta e era minha fórmula de
skate eu fiquei completamente apaixonada
viciada você tudo com muito carinho eu
comecei a se reconectar com outras
pessoas
a diferença que a minha e comecei a ver
que eu poderia impactar a vida de outras
pessoas positivamente fora da medicina
aí eu tava mudando a vida de algumas
pessoas falando sobre cabelo falando
sobre a autoestima na internet isso
sempre o impacto direto na minha
autoestima na minha felicidade na minha
satisfação pessoal eu comecei a ficar
menos ansiosa a dormir melhor meu
desempenho na faculdade começou a
melhorar muito eu tinha mais prazer
aprende a melhor conseguir dormir melhor
né e meu desempenho na faculdade começou
a melhorar muito porque você disse que
eu estava realmente respeitando a minha
totalidade inicialmente no canal eu não
contei que eu fazia medicina né eu não
queria que a monalisa médica tirar sol
forte das outras mas com o tempo
descobriram que eu fazer medicina e esse
passou a ser um tópico também no canal
para ele falava da minha rotina de tudo
como eu tinha passado no vestibular qual
era a minha
em cima isso pastor é um toque como
assim regular no canal mas a partir do
momento que eu contei que eu falei que
fazer medicina as críticas à pressão
essa demanda de se assemelhar com um
médico super-homem ideal voltou né então
recebia muita pergunta isso professores
o que é que eles acham mona pode ser
tatuagem na faculdade de medicina o
canal não passa trabalhando seus estudos
ainda veio a demanda do pessoal da do
marketing digital e do youtube né mano
você precisa escolher um nicho não dá
para falar de medicina de estudo e de
beleza no mesmo canal não tem nada a ver
felizmente eu consegui fazendo as coisas
do jeito que eu queria do meu jeitinho
as seis anos tem dado super certo e eu
entendi que eu não escolher uma só
narrativa eu não me escolher só uma
analisa
olá tudo aquilo na verdade eu sou tudo
isso né eu sou médico mas eu também sou
influenciadora digital eu sou o filha eu
sou uma de gato a sua esposa eu sou
militante vegana anti-racista e cada
hora algo novo e não me entenda mal
gente essa jornada não é a coisa mais
fácil do mundo tá mas vale muito a pena
vai ser a hora que a gente se perde
senhora que a gente sente essa cobrança
mais forte na verdade até hoje mesmo já
tendo uma carreira mesmo que consolidada
já já estou no caminho certo na medicina
sou feliz na minha profissão eu ainda
estou quadrada a minha semelhar aquele
médico branco de meia-idade e o que eu
acho que pior é que eu continuo sendo
lembrada de que eu não sou ele
diariamente diariamente algum paciente
ou até funcionário do hospital chega
para mim
a moça cadê o médico logo tu podia falar
com o médico sim mas você pode chamar o
médico para mim e você sabe onde é que o
médico está
oi isa algo que acontece diariamente
mesmo eu estando no consultório médico
sentado arrumadinha de jaleco escrito
messina ou médica isso acontece
diariamente e existe essa estranhamento
das pessoas realmente abrirem a porta do
consultório e não se depararem com
aquele médico branco de meia-idade até
hoje não tem touca touca equipamento de
proteção individual né tão falado nessas
áreas de floride se comporta o cabelo
crescer não tem eu tenho que usar duas
três toucas para conseguir ficar
protegida proteger os meus pacientes e
me proteger né das infecções e eu não
vou com cabelo assim gente solta eu vou
com cabelo bem preso mas realmente é um
tamanho muito pequeno que não dá não dá
para confortar um cabelo não branco e
uma touca de equipamento individual luva
tem entende mas
e para quê né tem tamanho diferente e
outra coisa que diariamente me lembra de
que eu não sou esse ideal é sempre a
única eu fui a única estudante negra na
minha turma a universidade federal de
alagoas que no nordeste né eu tenho
única estudante negra da minha turma e
agora na especialização em são paulo e
dermatologia que é uma das mais famosas
daqui eu também sou a única médica negra
essas são algumas formas ea sociedade
tende minnie mouse traje que eu não sou
aquele imaginário que eu não sou aquele
ideal mas a verdade é que eu não preciso
se você também não precisa ser a minha
missão aqui é realmente criar novos
imaginários gritar para o mundo que
precisamos de novas histórias precisamos
de sua história e da sua história
completa a busca pelo sucesso
profissional é só uma das suas
narrativas seja você
a localidade mostre as suas
singularidades ajude a construir um
mundo mais diverso e feliz essa é a
minha missão do mundo obrigada
[Aplausos]
e aí